first up coming in Roshan saying I'm an
introvert being introverted how can I
develop my communication skills what
advice would you have there for each of
our portion hey Russian now I've got
some great news where I'll use a couple
of other quotes actually from people I
think both Evan and I respect who are
amazing but but they're introverts and I
think we often forget we kind of have I
think actually part of social media in
the celebrity culture
you kind of expect everybody to be an
extra out there but they're not when you
when you when when people are very
authentic a lot of people are introverts
you know evidence shared with you before
on previous broadcasts about you know
how he's overcome and maybe he'll talk a
bit about that today but one guy we both
met and we think pretty amazing
entrepreneur Richard Branson his quote
is I had to train myself into becoming
more of an extrovert and we both met the
guy he's just very very humble super
nice guy cares passionately about our
customers always looking for the way to
disrupt an industry and then another one
from a completely different field
there's someone who read all the kind of
legendary Harry Potter books JK Rowling
she said you know I've been writing
almost continuously since the age of six
but I've never been so excited about
this idea I had them but my intense
immense frustration is I didn't have a
pen that worked and I was too shy to ask
anybody if I could borrow one you know
and that's well one of the most luminary
authors of our times and then someone in
our industry Bill Gates who's doing
amazing philanthropic work around the
world and leading massive campaign to do
things like stop at area I've obviously
built Microsoft and he kind of
acknowledges you know I think introverts
can do pretty well if you're clever you
can learn to get to the benefits of
being a really good interview about
thinking about really tough problems
about kind of reading everything you can
to just to push yourself very hard to
think of the edge and beyond the edge of
your area but you'd better team up with
extroverts to kind of do and tap into
both sets of skills so that you can
build a company who thrives both for
deep thinking but building the team also
to go out to the world and sell those
ideas so kind of I think you know what
does that mean it means there's a lot of
people around the world you should feel
very comfortable you know that a lot of
great business people or great
entrepreneurs are absolutely introvert
and I think you know my my most sort of
humble advice would be with all these
things as we talked about with people at
Martin Luther King take that first step
on a giant staircase and the easier you
know the more you pitch your idea the
more you picture to friends and families
in the society safe environment more
confidence you get and you know you you
can definitely overcome your level of
introversion and be very successful what
are your thoughts Evan because you know
you've been very um you showed a lot of
humility and humanity in this topic and
it's a very personal topic to you yeah
we only we talked about this either in
the last one of time before how we were
both introverted and that me not always
like it may not feel like it watching us
on these sessions but we're both
introverted and and I first of all I
think it's just understanding that being
an introvert can actually be a strength
for you in the ability to communicate
because yes you have to learn to talk
but you have to learn to talk in a way
that other people can understand and I
think introverts actually do a better
job of listening so that you can
understand the other person and so where
extroverts maybe need to do a better job
of listening introverts have that
already and so just happen into that I
was an ability to know what they want to
hear what they're you know excited about
and then give them a message that will
hit home and so first off for me would
just be disassociating the idea that
because I am an introvert I can't be a
success at being a communicator where
you can you just do it in a different
way you do it by listening really
intently and then sharing your message
you don't have to be yelling at the
front of a stage to communicate there's
a lot of different ways to get your
message out there and going I don't
think and I don't think you should like
I don't think you need to become that
person who's yelling on stage go all in
on
your strengths and use that ability to
listen really well to give a message
that really resonates with the person
that you're trying to connect with